Vì vậy, Ràn đã nhất chỉ tổ chức vòng đàn phản vòng ngày 29,
tại Oman sau khi hai bên thống lất thay đổi để điểm
từ Istang-Buôn Sarm, Mú Scat theo đuyện hiệu của Tehran.
Dinh Yen vẫn đồng về nội dung miệ sử ướp vẫn chưa được thảo gỡ.
Dì Ràn cho biết các cuộc đàn phản chỉ nên tập trung và chương trình hạt nhân.
Có đây là điều kiện thành chốt, để đối thoại tiếp diễn.
Một qua trước các cầu Yeran khẳng định,
chương trình tên lượng đảnh đạo của nước này không năm trên bản đàn phản.
Đúng thời gian báo việc mở giọng lỗi dùng có thể hiện tiến trình đối thoại bị đổ bởi
phy nghĩ lại đường ra lập trường khác.
Mọi chiều mắc cô Rubeo nói,
Washington sẽ sạm đàn phản nhưng bên cạnh các vấn đề hạnh nhân
các cuộc thảo lượng phản bao gồm cả trình trình thế lượng.
Vá trò của Yeran đối pháp các lực lượng uống nghiệm trong khu vực trung đông và tình hình trong lưỡc.
Tổng thống đoàn tròng cũng cho biết,
mặc dù Yeran đáng đàn phản đoệm miếng sống cạnh báo,
để Héran đean rất lòng ai, nếu không đặt được một thật thuật.
Cuộc gặp diễn ra trong đối cảnh các thẳng sống phương ra tâm,
khi Mỹ tăng cường hiện dịch của sửa cả chúng đông và Yeran đối mặt sự át ngay cán lớn,
sau các lản sống đều tình trong lưỡc.